shoot for the moon and if you fall short
at least you'll be amongst the stars
it's a nice sentiment if only it were
true it's more like shoot for the moon
and if you fall short
you'll be amongst the enormous amount of
trash orbiting the earth now that's true
so don't fall shorts or maybe thus not
to shoot for the moon like most people
I'm open to taking risks as long as I'm
guaranteed a positive outcome that comes
at no cost to myself so when people say
things like take risks be bold change
the world I'm left with a burning
unanswered question why especially since
doing such things might actually kill me
but the answer started to take shape
during my time at Harvard with credit
dudes for former undergrad for the last
five years I've been a resident tutor in
Mather house
where it's truly been a joy to work with
hundreds of amazing students to whom
I've doled out such insightful wisdom as
do not go to grad school unless you're
willing to endure long periods of
failure on a daily basis punctuated only
rarely by incremental progress am i
right one day over lunch a student told
me she was nervous about talking to a
professor about a low exam score before
she left I said just remember that you
have intrinsic worth apart from your
accomplishments and she was stunned and
said is that really true I mean doesn't
everyone judge you based on your
accomplishments oh right but the thing
about intrinsic worth is that you have
it inherently it's part of your
personhood you can't earn it with
accomplishments and therefore you can't
lose it with failures nothing can take
it away but it's easy to forget since
the world often reduces us to the some
of our achievements and has a long
memory of our failures it's tough to
believe something if no one else affirms
it even if it is true two weeks later I
saw the same student on the m2 shuttle
heading back to Cambridge from the
medical school it's two miles away so
during the next 45 minutes
bus she asked me how my research was
going poorly as usual I replied and
immediately she said well remember you
have intrinsic worth apart from your
accomplishments
I had to smile a student actually
remembered something I said
but seriously her reminder really struck
me and as I pondered it over the years I
realized that intrinsic worth is at the
core of resolving those nagging
questions why take risks when they come
at such a cost and how to even dare in
the face of crushing failure having
worth that cannot be lost provides the
strength to persevere you have a reserve
you can draw upon when everything is
falling apart and you feel unjustly
pressed on all sides not everything is
on the line because even when you fail
you still have worth you can still get
up again failure doesn't have to destroy
you which means you can afford to be
bold to resist the crowd to do what's
right
usually challenges to take risks
ultimately appeal to our narcissism with
promises of high-risk high-reward
however this is an ineffective motivator
since most of us are jaded low-risk
high-reward people it's also called
being logical but recognizing intrinsic
worth in other people broadens our
perspective my student leader told me
that knowing her own worth changed her
life
how much more life-changing disruptive
even would it be if we affirmed worth
not only in ourselves but also in other
people what if we acted like it wouldn't
we be a bit more compassionate a bit
more considerate in criticism a bit more
courageous to fight injustice how
different our news headlines would be
a person has inherent value it's part of
our shared humanity and that should
compel us to act boldly for the sake of
others even when it's costly recognizing
intrinsic worth simultaneously motivates
and sustains us to take those risks to
change the world and we mustn't think
that changing the world only applies to
special people with special
circumstances to help the poor or the
sick or a developing country far away
every person fundamentally desires to be
fully known and fully loved despite
their flaws in essence to have their
intrinsic worth affirmed
so as my student did for me remind each
other in the midst of life's
trivialities and great opportunities you
have extraordinary worth apart from your
accomplishments and nothing can remove
it not even yourself and if you live
confidence that your worth is already
secured then you might actually begin to
change the world
you